Joe Biden had a rough summer in 2021, and
his September and October poll numbers haven’t
shown much improvement.
Gallup reported recently that Biden’s support
has fallen 14 points since June.
He has lost significant ground among politically
consequential independents.
Biden’s third quarter polling average is
higher than Donald Trump’s but lower than
all other presidents Gallup tracks.
The president’s ratings have deteriorated
on handling the economy, foreign policy, and
COVID.
But he has also lost ground on a range of
personal qualities.
In the mid-October Economist/YouGov poll,
38 percent said they liked him.
That was 43 percent in their late January-early
February poll.
53 percent in Pew’s September poll said
he cares about the needs of ordinary people.
62 percent gave that response in March.
44 percent believe he is mentally sharp, down
from 54 percent.
High personal ratings can cushion the impact
of negative performance.
It’s early, and President Biden can recover,
but it is harder to pull numbers up than watch
them go down.
How well do you think Joe Biden's doing?
Let us know in our poll. Also, let us know what other topics you'd like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds.
And be sure to like and subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.